devrait être paradisiaque les plages
californiennes font normalement rêver de
nombreux Américains mais après neuf
rivières atmosphériques Santa Cruz
quelques peu perdu de ses charmes
l'eau baisse enfin mais il faut
maintenant nettoyer
internet
malgré les dégâts Tony Burban ne
regrettent pas d’être venu s'installer
ici il y a 5 ans
si le prix est payé dit-il pour vivre
dans un si bel endroit
une pompe tire enfin le sable qui
empêchait les égouts de fonctionner
l'eau pourra s'écouler pour de bons
même entouré d'eau le dépanneur
d'Isabelle Flores demeure ouvert son
garage est toutefois inondé depuis des
semaines et les épuisés
[Applaudissements]
dans le côté de Santa Cruz les dégâts ne
se limite pas qu'au bord de mer plus
haut dans les collines ce sont les
arbres qui ont causé le gros dédommage
de gigantesques eucalyptus autant que
des pins rouges centenaire que le seul
imbibé d'eau ne pouvait plus retenir
se compte quand même chanceux l'arbre
est tombé sur sa voiture mais parier sa
maison
la panne de courant a été spectaculaire
mais contrairement à d'autres secteurs
il fut de courte durée depuis pouvoir
atmosphérique et demain j'étais value à
plus d'un milliards de dollars partout
en Californie des désastres d'une telle
ampleur que le président Giovanni a
déclaré l'état d'urgence fédérale dans
trois comtés californiens comme ici afin
qu'il puisse recevoir davantage d'aide
financière
ici Mathieu Gohier Radio-Canada